lately I've been looking back at some of
the older viz mangas because they redraw
some really weird stuff what happened
here back in the day visit
the Japanese Sun
go as well as reformat speech bubbles to
fit texts better the problem is that
meant they needed to extend the original
art themselves and unfortunately the
folks they had doing this didn't always
hit the mark like poor Napa here who
seems to be having his breast implant
fail in the redraw but of course viz
isn't the only one doing bad redraws
here in fact shueisha themselves did
some redraws once in a while to clean up
mistakes like the armbands they gave 10
Shin on here these aren't as bad as the
piccolo ear but they definitely look a
bit Yeah odd compared to toriyama's
Immaculate line art